I loved going back to Hogwarts. Of course I did
It looks very familiar to anyone who saw the Potter movies, but obviously the teaching staff are different
Those names, the stories, the histories that sit in the back of our mind from the Potter series
Begin to weave their way into beasts.I have some questions for you
Dumbledore
Actually be shooting here at Lake Hawk where three of the films are shot, it's quite amazing really
When I walked on and saw all the trunks and Hogwarts stickers and things like that
It's pretty amazing. It's like the ultimate childhood fantasy into play witches and wizards
But it was slightly odd out-of-body experience because I've watched with everyone else those classes
And suddenly to be in it you're in there doing it. But then you look back on as yourself and realize how special it was
Go ahead Newt
Ridiculous
I felt quite sentimental going back to Hogwarts
I'm scared Professor Dumbledore
Everyone is scared of something
Ridiculous
Newt, you're next
That's an unusual one what Mr. Scamander fears above everything else is
Having to work in an office, sir
Go ahead Newt
Ridiculous
Magic Brooms
Only in rare souls
Still in the skulking shadows
Of course the old ways serve us no longer
I take it you've heard the rumors
Grindelwald has a vision
That he would rise to dominance over the Wizarding World
So you're asking me to help hunt him down
I can't move against Grindelwald. It has to be you
In your shoes, I'd probably refuse too. It's late. Good Evening Newt
Oh come on!
You underestimate your talents Mr. Scamander
Their arrogance is a key to our victory
Muggles are not lesser
Not disposable
You're too good Newt. You've never met a monster you couldn't love.
Credence
Mr. Scamander, do you think Dumbledore will mourn for you?
Are you ghost? No, I'm alive. But, I'm an alchemist and therefore immortal.
Oh
Nicolas Flamel
Jacob Kowalski
You don't look a day over 375